all right but we are going to begin with
the latest on that terrifying shooting
on the new york city subway system
yesterday police are looking for this
man 62 year old frank james and part of
a wider investigation into the attack
leaving 23 people injured yesterday
james has not been formally identified
as a suspect but police are looking for
him in connection to the shooting
nonetheless the gunman whoever he is
started shooting on a subway train in
western brooklyn a train filled with
people on their way to work
10 of the injured people were shot
struck by bullets police say that if the
shooter's gun
had not jammed this could have been a
far worse situation multiple clips were
found at the scene mulalengi is at the
scene in brooklyn where police are
describing the one man in this case that
they're looking for very distinctive
outfit he showed up in mulla good
morning
good morning tony as you mentioned no
suspect has been named james right now
is a person of interest in this
investigation and they believe he rented
this u-haul truck found yesterday after
its keys were discovered at the scene
at the brooklyn subway station where the
attack happened also a video apparently
posted by james on monday showing him
talking about killing people and wanting
to watch people die
[Music]
at about 8 30 a.m tuesday panicked
passengers on a manhattan-bound train
fled for their lives after a gunman set
off a smoke bomb then fired more than 30
rounds into the crowd
in another car video shows riders
trapped in a thick cloud of smoke
waiting for the train to pull into the
station i get off the train the first
thing i smell the smoke that hit me in
the face was not normal train smoke this
is like something's burning it's thick
it's heavy and people just start running
towards me
in fear sam karkimo arrived at the 36th
street station on a different train saw
the commotion and started filming women
are screaming people are screaming
someone's saying something about guns
people are like covered in blood as
they're running towards us
passengers were seen dragging each other
to safety or performing first aid while
others fled to the street above
and coming up the stairs i saw maybe a
16 year old that was shot in the knee it
was just a scary moment it was everyone
was packed together
and i didn't know what happened until
after investigators recovered a tote bag
that included a hatchet two gas
canisters and a nine millimeter handgun
that apparently jammed during the attack
along with three extended magazines and
discharged shell casings witnesses
described the shooter as a dark-skinned
man in an orange worker's vest who put
on a gas mask before opening fire
we are truly fortunate that this was not
significantly worse than it is
some good news is that none of the
injuries appear to be life-threatening
we will use every resource we can to
bring those to justice who continue to
prey on the citizens of new york
police have announced up to a 50
thousand dollar reward for information
in this shooting and this morning the
train station here in brooklyn has
reopened to passengers you can see them
trickling in and out and trains are
running again in both directions as the
transit authority here in new york says
police have concluded their
investigation down on the subway station
gail
people still need to use the subway
thank you very much mola what